we have some pretty exciting breaking
news to share for all of you
as the duke and duchess of sussex have
just announced the birth of their
daughter
the news came with all the usual fanfare
of a royal baby but this time
made on harry and megan's terms
almost 48 hours after their little girl
was born
they told the world on their charity
website
on june 4th we were blessed with the
arrival of our daughter
lily she is more than we could have ever
imagined and we remain grateful
for the love and prayers we've felt from
across the globe
thank you for your continued kindness
and support during this very special
time for our family
i think the way that they have announced
their daughter's birth i think very much
reflects and represents the fact that
they are now able to be in control of
how they do things and that's
very much what they wanted to achieve
when they step back they've been able to
wait for two days before making the
announcement something that would have
been
very difficult for them to achieve if
they were still working royals
we knew they were due to have a little
girl after they again broke with royal
tradition
and announced it during their interview
with oprah
but for a couple who've moved away from
royal life they could not have chosen a
more
regal first name calling their daughter
lilybet
or lily the queen's childhood nickname
and a tribute to her majesty
and her middle name diana a loving nod
from harry to his late mother
an hour and a half after the
announcement
buckingham hales said the queen the
prince of wales
and the duchess of cornwall and the duke
and duchess of cambridge
have been informed and are delighted
with the news of the birth of a daughter
for the duke and duchess of sussex the
separation
from the rest of the family has been
fractious
and while part of it was about having
more privacy for their family
and escaping the uk's tabloid culture
the arrival of their second child is
only likely to fuel the
international interest i think that the
baby's birth is definitely going to
increase interest in megan and harry in
the u.s because
every time there's a little baby people
always want to know more of whether it's
a royal or any other type of celebrity
here in the us
if you read people magazine or any of
the other sort of supermarket
celebrity magazines that you see babies
are on the cover of them pretty much all
the time
prince william's daughter princess
charlotte also has
elizabeth and diana as her middle names
in many ways the queen's 11th
great-grandchild born in california will
have a very different
upbringing from her cousin but in her
names lilybet
diana mountbatten windsor will forever
be very much
part of the windsor dynasty rhiannon
mills
sky news